au début de ma carrière je chante m et
j'ai eu des problèmes auditifs qui m'ont
empêché de continuer à chanter donc
comme j'avais déjà composé beaucoup de
chansons je cherchais des interprètes
alors pour commencer j'ai cherché un
interprète
c'est moïse elle sort avec lequel j'ai
travaillé pendant dix ans et nous avons
eu beaucoup de succès d'ailleurs on a
fait de véritables tubes qui ont été
repris pendant le carnaval notamment nos
jours et boules et it's à ambon brûle ce
sont des tubes non l'auteur a par
exemple on n'en parle pas beaucoup mais
c'est aussi un oscar de la chasse aux
créoles donc avec un moïse à ceux dont
on a travaillé pendant 10 ans et par la
suite j'ai amélioré si vous voulez mes
compositions
j'ai travaillé sur d'autres thèmes comme
la complète d'une fille mais par exemple
qui est un slot qui raconte l'histoire
d'une fille mère chassé par sa famille
et tous enfin bref j'ai fait des
chansons des slows j'ai fait des boléros
j'ai fait des jets même j'ai même écrit
à un certain moment
un reggae mais je n'ai pas enregistré ce
disque je n'ai pas eu les moyens de le
faire tout de suite donc ciblé et là
j'ai voulu varier mes compositions mais
a par la suite
au début je faisais que du folklore la
biguine mazurka valse créole begin vidé
mais après j'ai commencé à faire des
compositions plus profonde plus plus
sensible plus plus générale aussi parce
que la complète d'une fille mère a été
chantée en france dans d'autres
jobs dans deux hommes j'ai fait aussi de
la musique pour la chorale du fassois
avec le père elie et notamment le
célèbre honoré oui donc
il n'y a pas que ça mais de se
développer et il ya eu d'autres artistes
alors il ya eu d'autres artistes il ya
après mon sens un d'or comme j'avais des
chansons que moussa tandja s'était pas
son style et tout donc je cherchais une
chanteuse et c'est là que j'ai découvert
ses valises pépins avec qui j'ai c'est
que je continue à travailler parce
qu'elle veut absolument que je revienne
alors je suis en train d'y réfléchir je
sais pas mais j'ai découvert cela ne
serait pas là 14 15 ans et nous avons
nous avons travaillé sont le jusqu'à
présent jusqu'à présent j'ai aussi lancé
claudy largen que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
car j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec lui et
on a en a gagné d'ailleurs compte de la
chance pour la chasse au kenya avec le
dealer jeunes notamment une biguine qui
s'appelait ticotin que ça ce sont des
histoires toutes mes chansons rythmées
biguines mazurkas valses c'est juste ça
non seulement du succès mais ce sont des
histoires tirées de la vie de la réalité
des choses que je voyais quand
j'entendais donc c'est ça a été une très
bonne chose moi je suis très satisfait
de ça j'ai fait aussi des chasses au
spirituel pour la chorale du fonds soit
gay qui ont été chantées dans les
églises